♪ ♪
>> Laura: WITH THE NEWS THAT
FOX BROKE LAST NIGHT ABOUT THE
TRUE EXTENT OF CHINA’S
CORONAVIRUS COVER-UP, WE AT
THE INGRAHAM ANGLE FELT
OBLIGATED TO TELL YOU -- WELL,
WE TOLD YOU SO.
CHINA’S AMBITIONS HAVE NEVER
BEEN A SECRET YET OVER THE YEARS
OUR POLITICAL MEDIA FINANCIAL
AND YES, OUR HEALTH EXPERTS,
HAVE CLAIMED AND IT WAS IN YOUR
BEST INTEREST TO COZY UP TO THE
COMMUNIST PARTY.
WHY?
WELL, SO THEY COULD MAKE A QUICK
BUCK AND FLOOD OUR COUNTRY WITH
CHEAP IMPORTED GOODS -- MUCH TO
AMERICAN WORKERS, GIVEN HOW
DEVASTATING THIS ENTIRE COVID-19
PANDEMIC IS PROVEN TO BE, I
THOUGHT IT WAS IMPORTANT TO
REMIND YOU OF THOSE WHO IGNORED
THIS GLOBAL DANGER.
AND DISMISSED IT ALTOGETHER.
I GIVE YOU THE CHINA THREAT
DENIERS.
I WANT TO BEGIN THREE DECADES
AGO WHEN CHINA WAS STRUGGLING
MIGHTILY TO MERGE IN THE MODERN
WORLD.
AS "THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" --
IT’S DIFFERENT TO REMEMBER HOW
ECONOMICALLY BACKWARD THE
COUNTRY WAS IN THE EARLY
1990s.
INFLATION HIT 24% IN 1994.
NEARLY 60% OF THE POPULATION
LIVED ON LESS THAN A BUCK 90 A
DAY.
BUT CHINA HAD A PLAN.
THE NATIONS COMMUNIST PARTY
LEADERS WOULD WOO WESTERN
ECONOMIC ELITES IN ORDER TO GAIN
ACCESS TO THE POWERFUL WORLD
TRADE ORGANIZATION.
IN ONE OF THEIR KEY TARGETS WAS
FORMER PRESIDENT BILL CLINTON.
AND THEREFORE RAISE, WELL, THEY
WEREN’T SUBTLE AT ALL.
DURING CLINTON’S 9096 REELECTION
CAMPAIGN, THERE WERE -- SENIOR
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS IN CHINA TO
FUNNEL ILLICIT FOREIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS INTO HIS COFFERS
AT HIS CAMPAIGN.
JUST A FEW SHORT YEARS AGO AND
YEARS LATER, EXCUSE ME, CLINTON
WAS ALREADY TRYING TO CONVINCE
AMERICANS THAT THEY NEEDED TO
WELCOME CHINA INTO THE GLOBAL
TRADING COMMUNITY.
>> AMERICA HAS A STAKE IN
CHINA’S SUCCESS.
IN CHINA IT IS OVERCOME THE
CHALLENGES IT HAS SPACES AT HOME
HOME.
A CHINA THAT IS INTEGRATED INTO
THE INSTITUTIONS, THE PROMOTE
GLOBAL NORMS.
>> Laura: WORLD TRADE
ORGANIZATION.
ONE YEAR AFTER THAT, COMMUNIST
PROPERLY, WITH CHINA’S POSITION
IN THE WTO SECURED, CLINTON AND
FEDERAL RESERVE CHAIR ALAN
GREENSPAN HELD A RESIN FOR
DOMINIC TRIUMPHANT ROSE
GARDEN --
>> AS CHINA’S CITIZENS
EXPERIENCE ECONOMIC GAINS, SO
WILL THE AMERICAN FIRMS THAT
PRAYED IN THEIR EXPANDING
MARKETS.
INTO THE WTO WILL CREATE NEW
OPPORTUNITIES FOR AMERICAN
BUSINESSES AND FARMERS.
>> I BELIEVE THAT CHAIRMAN
GREENSPAN HAS ESTABLISHED A
PRETTY GOOD RECORD FOR KNOWING
WHAT IS IN AMERICA’S ECONOMIC
INTEREST.
>> Laura: I CAN’T EVEN LISTEN
TO THAT.
TO BE FAIR, IT WASN’T JUST THE
CLINTON ADMINISTRATION.
JUST TWO YEARS LATER
GEORGE W. BUSH ECHOED HIS
PREDECESSORS NAIVE SENTIMENTS.
>> CHINA IS ON A RISING PATH.
AND AMERICA WELCOMES THE
EMERGENCE OF A STRONG AND
PEACEFUL AND PROSPEROUS CHINA.
>> Laura: HOW TO THAT ALL WORK
FOR US?
AND THEN OBAMA OF COURSE ECHOED
BUSH, LIKE LITERALLY.
>> THE UNITED STATES WELCOMES
THE RISE OF A PROSPEROUS,
PEACEFUL, AND STABLE CHINA.
WE WANT CHINA TO DO WELL.
>> Laura: WELL -- [LAUGHS]
AFTER THEY SHARE NOTES?
TODAY PASSED NOTES ALONG?
IT’S CRAZY.
SO WHAT DID AMERICA GET OUT OF
CHINA’S INCLUSIONS INTO THE WTO?
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
MANUFACTURING JOBS.
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY LIFT
DOMINIC RIPPED OFF LEFT AND
RIGHT.
MEANWHILE, CHINA BROKEN PROMISES
TO LET FOREIGN BANKS PARTICIPATE
IN THERE -- YOU KNOW, AND ALL OF
THEIR OWN BUSINESS.
THEY UNDERVALUE THEIR CURRENCY.
THEY GOT HUGE MARGINS FOR YEARS.
YOU THINK THAT WOULD UPSET THE
TITANS OF ALL STREETLIGHT FORMER
GOLDMAN SACHS CEO, RIGHT?
>> CHINA’S RISE OBVIOUSLY IS
IMPORTANT FOR CHINA, BUT SUPPORT
FOR EVERYBODY IN THE WORLD.
I THINK CHINA’S LEADERSHIP HAS
PROVED IN ITS COMPETENCE OVER
THE LAST COUPLE OF DECADES.
>> Laura: WELL, AT LEAST HE
DEFENDED TRUMP’S TARIFFS LAST,
BUT THAT WAS AFTER HE HAD LEFT
HIS POSITION AT GOLDMAN WHERE HE
HAD A FINANCIAL INTEREST IN
PLAYING NICE.
ALL THESE YEARS LATER AFTER ALL
THE TRADE ABUSES, ALL THAT
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY THEFT, ALL
THE MARKET MANIPULATION, THE
PROVOCATIONS IN THE SOUTH
CHINA SEA, WITH THE CONTINUED TO
DODO TO TERRORIZE TAIWAN, THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
CARRIED YOU WOULD THINK THAT THE
POLITICIANS IN BOTH PARTIES,
ESPECIALLY THE ONES WHO WILL BE
THE PARTY STANDARD-BEARERS IN
2020, THAT THEY WOULD BE VERY
CLEAR EYED NOW ABOUT THE CHINA
THREAT WE FACE.
>> CHINA IS GOING TO EAT OUR
LUNCH.
COME ON, MAN.
I MEAN -- YOU KNOW, THEY’RE NOT
BAD FOLKS, FOLKS.
BUT GUESS WHAT?
THEY’RE NOT COMPETITION FOR US.
>> CHINA IS NOT A PROBLEM.
IF WE INVEST IN REMEMBER WHO WE
ARE.
>> Laura: NOT OUR PROBLEM AT
ALL.
LOOK AROUND, JOE.
LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED TO AMERICA
OVER THE LAST FOUR WEEKS.
WE LOST ALL OF OUR JOB GAINS
SINCE THE LAST OF COURSE
RECESSION.
NOW IT’S TIME FOR CHINA TO ENTER
THE FOREFRONT OF THE AMERICAN
POLITICAL CONVERSATION.
AND IF YOU SEE SOMEONE DENYING
WHAT CHINA HAS DONE TO AMERICA,
OUR WORKERS, OUR PEOPLE, NOW OUR
HEALTH WITH THE WAY THEY HANDLE
THIS VIRUS, ASK YOURSELF, WHAT’S
IN IT FOR THEM?